mainactivity is launched when you start
the app at the bottom of main activity
we have placeholder fragment placeholder
fragment was generated by the template
we use when creating our project a
fragment is a modular container within
your activity in later lessons we'll
look at how to use multiple fragments in
a single activity and will actually
explain why we're using them at all but
for now our activity contains just this
one fragment so here in placeholder
fragment is where we reference our UI
layout resource called fragment main
this XML file lives in the resources res
directory of our project folder you can
see other kinds of resources here
besides layouts such as design assets or
drawables or strings when our activity
runs it creates this placeholder
fragment which then inflate the XML
layout resource converting everything in
the XML file to a hierarchy of view
objects in memory by holding ctrl or
command depending on your operating
system and clicking on this reference to
fragment main Android studio will drop
us right into the visual layout editor
once we're inside a layout XML file we
can switch between the design tab where
we can drag and drop new UI elements and
modify the layout visually and the text
tab where we can see and edit the XML
that defined the layout and UI elements
all of the views we'll talk about here
ultimately extend the view base class
the template we used gives us a relative
layout with some padding around the
edges we'll get into layout features
like padding and margins later inside
our relative layout is a single textview
that says hello world
edit text is a text entry field that is
an editable version of textview it is
many options such as whether it supports
single or multi line there are several
styled versions of edit text in the text
field section of Android studio such as
name email phone or postal address each
one sets the soft keyboard into an
appropriate entry mode image view
Blaz the image defined in its source
attribute it has some really useful
features like zooming and cropping if
the source image is too large or has a
different aspect ratio than the image
view itself a ListView is a special kind
of view that contains one or more views
that are replicated to display sets of
data in this case this single text view
is used to display the weather
information replicated throughout the
list
we'll get into much more detail about
list views later on